you see an enchanted forest
[Music]
papa that was epic
all right King Agner we're gonna need
more details on that bedtime story you
told young Elsa and Anna your fairy tale
was cryptic dark and foreboding we need
more to satisfy our curiosity about the
enchanted forest that lies as far north
as you can go there are intriguing
mysteries to reveal and your daughters
are waiting to find out everything so
can we come to the next bedtime story
for Jama party because anna was right
this story is epic the king told his
young daughters a story about the people
in the enchanted forest of the north but
he left out some important details we
were able to patch together some clues
as to what happened to the people in
this faraway land where did you learn
magic the new frozen to trailer gave
away more secrets than you think and
we're here to spill the tea watch until
the ends for a shocking reveal about
Elsa's distant relative far away as
north as we can go once stood an
enchanted forest it was a magical place
but something went wrong since then no
one can get in or out
King ignores words sparked the spirit of
curiosity and inventor in his young
daughters hearts but was his bedtime
story a form of entertainment or a
warning we know that the enchanted
forest was a magical place it was home
to a peaceful tribe of people in the
latest trailer we see King Agner as a
young lad who is swept away by a young
Queen I Doudna but then something bad
happened and it made the people of the
forest suspicious of the outside world
some evil force caused the people of the
enchanted forest to be trapped on the
inside but why our queen i deunan King
ignore the outside of the forest let's
explore these questions and more we also
found a striking resemblance between one
of the people of the Enchanted Forest
and Elsa watch until the end to find out
who it is the fog must have some magical
powers that keeps the people of the
forest trapped inside or was set up to
prevent something from getting out the
people of the forest were stunned when
Elsa and Anna were able to cross the fog
was the fog protecting the people of the
outside world from some sort of threat
maybe the fog keeps those giant rock
monsters from crossing over Elsa used
her powers to Kris
why's the fog so they could cross into
the mysterious land only those with
magical powers can cross over
we have always feared houses powers were
too much for this world
this means it was else's destiny to
reconnect with the people of the forest
born with the powers of caste born and
they're getting stronger however the
people of the enchanted forest weren't
exactly welcoming they must be really
scared of outsiders and intruders
they attacked Elsa and her crew right
there on the spot why are they so
suspicious of others they must have lost
a great deal to whoever is responsible
for the fog they started out as peaceful
and happy but now they are terrified and
are aggressively standing their ground
the people of the enchanted forest are
probably scared for their lives perhaps
they will help Elsa on her quest to
defeat the mysterious evil that has kept
them prisoner for so long we know that
something went wrong in the enchanted
force that caused people to be trapped
inside indefinitely while others were
forced out now that they know that Elsa
has powers the people of the enchanted
forests will help Elsa and Anna save
arendelle at all costs let's talk about
the initial conflict we see in the
trailer from the trailer we can see that
the people of the enchanted forest lived
happily for a time but then there was
some sort of battle soldiers were
crossing swords and the firestorm
erupted we're not sure where that
firestorm came from perhaps there is
another person in the forest with powers
over the element of fire but who who it
is could be the one responsible for the
foggy lockdown of the enchanted forest
will also have to fight this fire
sorceress is she the threat to arendelle
maybe I dunno and this fire sorceress
were at odds and their conflict caused
war that would explain why I dunno and
Agner wound up outside the Enchanted
Forest but just who did they leave
behind
surely Agner naidu now had loved ones
trapped on the wrong side of the mist we
know Anna and Elsa didn't have any
family in arendelle do you have to go
you'll be fine Elsa or they would have
been there after they lost their parents
so who is on the other side of the fog
we think the answer to that is the
- the secret of Elsa's powers when Elsa
met the people of the forest they were
shocked to see her using magic they
asked her how she learned to use it now
we know from the first movie that Elsa
didn't learn magic she was born with it
so are all the people in the Enchanted
Forest capable of learning magic -
perhaps they were stunned by Elsa and
her powers because they realized that
she is a descendant of the royal house
[Applause]
[Music]
we think she has a distant relative who
has been trapped in the forest since
before she was born did you notice the
woman with the white hair in the
enchanted forest
doesn't she look familiar the only other
character in frozen with white hair is
Elsa could this be a distant relative of
Elsa and Ana's we think so in fact the
white haired woman could be Elsa and on
his grandmother if that's true she will
have a lot of answers that Elsa seeks
what do you think is behind the crazy
purple fires in the enchanted forest let
us know in the comments subscribe to our
channel to be the first to see our
latest videos and click the thumbs up
button while you're at it thanks for
watching the things see you next time
[Music]